[Music]
just are rivet Bob matter Bobby yo yo no
no five four three two why everybody
have a good time everybody gonna have a
good time tonight 2017 good Hollywood
nice honey honey honey Hollywood man
welcome to the podcast healthy Elmo
create day okay I'm okay I'm okay day
and um I want to introduce um wait a
minute do ye yeah wait a second remember
together Oh relax bro don't know that
you're on it yeah dude I don't want me
to start all over bro all right i mean
chruch i gotta start everybody have a
good and everybody gonna have a good
time tonight Hollywood nerds 2070 gonna
have a kid yeah we got our kalila we got
Gilbert's we got Georgetown USA with
this [ __ ] funky bass we don't only
face George and we got his geek cousin
uh rice rice ball my idiot and one of my
favorites Ian Edwards give him raw
deposit bag because when she walked into
this world I gave her a hug that was a
little too long we warned you yeah we're
gonna hug for 10 minutes out of respect
I know I feel like you've chosen the
right woman I know and I honor that
every time I see her I know honor that's
like me like respecting the choice you
bound I can't be made but also he knows
that you've always been my plan B right
you know we haven't done realized though
it's been going on for years and you and
you should thank me for being a shitty
plan B
thank you love of yours keep going it's
a pretty good plan betta yeah it's
pretty good number one question you're
healthy he does yoga he does yoga just
started yeah I didn't know the bad
people to show up buddy is that racial
or not because i wanna i want to listen
it's MLK day MLK day right I don't want
any problem okay sure I forgot about the
riot daily right at bonita all right
Bobby when you call me through there
yeah yeah yeah if you call me today use
ice wife [ __ ] guy Natron know why
call your day job I called you a choice
urban bother you called i know that's
not your Natron oh my god I did I go
what son Nate Nate you want to do the
pod guy she goes no I have done busy the
next week but then it we got them and I
also want to say this you and I are
heterosexual correct i know i am know
what I can only speak from where I need
you to do you think I'm heterosexual you
are good yeah you can you also oh yeah
yeah Bobby I think I think you are a
hundred percent straight it's just that
your buttholes game I do have a very gay
but it is very gay yeah um but I don't
sexual tension between us you or no no
no no be real though there is something
going on no water shut the [ __ ] up
Jabbar I'm trying to be real on my
podcast okay what I see you right do I
not physically assault you yeah but you
physically assault a lot of dudes no no
I'm very picky diverse who do I
physically assault you doc doc whatever
you have in common sometimes I'm okay to
make MLK day I'm okay yeah sometimes ooh
I'm sure you are told coolio nah that
much not as much your mcallen no no no
can we cuz he does it reciprocal with
your thumb about medical cases right
yeah you get uncomfortable all right so
you guys sometimes I like to lock you in
plays and I know that sir I know their
sexual turn-on between yeah when you
hold me I'm trying to get away tiny
attention then yeah I just want to
figure out what it is about him but I
just would really love I would just say
this to uncomfortableness no it's not
what it is I think this is what it is i
think i think your beloved in the comedy
you know industry and especially in
stand-up that's why eyes that's where
I'm know Ian and you know you over for
Rogan you know me Conan O'Brien produce
your album um you're like in the mix
with a lot of like really good camp
you're also arm a guy who like myself is
crossover in terms of like we can play
white room no that's we we tend to play
regular rooms but everyone else plays so
there's just a lot of things about you
that I am I really admire but there's
also i just find you sexually appetizer
advertising i'm not going to the spot Oh
foie gras I did oh I thought you're on
my side oh yeah get my man back neither
of you are thinking I'll occupiers and
be no I'm here I'm better yep see right
there yeah he's questionable yeah yeah
that you there we talked about him go to
the spot I did my part so i take him
into punk rock hobbit what's his name
hip-hop yeah delray hello ya Punk Robert
and I go let's go small Korean spa and
then so they go and like if I go to the
spa with any guy mm-hmm especially the
Korean Won you get naked you know but
this fool and is the [ __ ] punk punk
rock hobbit were the short so I know
they're short Sarah it has to go to an
area of the spa where I know that where
they are there two steps I had to give
it to them another in the steam room
with their [ __ ] short fund there
isn't that like against Korean spa
policy it is but they have a for whites
and blacks I guess so sorry there you go
I know what does it uncle why don't you
want me you just
exposures up to me is it ran general or
are you gonna listen you you've
assaulted me in clothes there's no way
I'm gonna give you a shot wow I really
have a self it's not even it's not even
the small rules like this is a body I
was with somebody else that doesn't
physically put your hands on me yeah i
know i'm gonna change that about myself
with ummm i really am because you and i
have not only stand up in common but we
also are huge fans of soccer no he's a
man you fan do you guys know that ooh we
did saw the documentary on slots on last
week other than our own yeah that's like
it's not the best one it just basically
goes back and forth between his career
and I acts and his last year in Malmo so
we like in when he was like 18 19 when
he was just starting yeah it's really
good and how when he first got to i ax
there was so much pressure because they
spent so much money on him in that first
year it wasn't great oh yeah and then in
the second year he came alive and it's a
pretty good document if you like you
know soccer know or if you like just
sports in general use you really think
you know how he's always jumping from
team to team two team maybe you realize
that it's because his whole life he's he
was raised by gypsies yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I played soccer like a gypsy
yeah right and also he at because I you
know I talked about in this podcast be
the photo with him and PK oh yeah yeah
you know that photo yeah you showed me
that I should I don't know everybody
yeah so basically on a lot on eve of a
[ __ ] who plays for men you used to play
for barcelona and he was leaving
Barcelona and he was saying goodbye to
draw PK who's a defender he's still
there who's married to Shakira and um
they take a photo of them basically
[ __ ] we're saying goodbye a lot that
very intimately let me intimately let me
ask you a question my friends for two
straight dude you and I you and I let's
see you and I work anymore you and I
world war any more like we're Nam right
it and we saw the [ __ ] right I mean we
saw people die burn you know I got
shrapnel in my ass 190 meters listen and
you as a brother you carry me back to
the foxhole and you just take the
[ __ ] shrapnel in my ass you know then
one by one right first of all that's
good the Red Cross guys I wanted you to
I want to do it you do it yeah but the
red car no I want you to do it this is
what I would do what if I think there's
gonna be some shrapnel going in your hat
I have to pick out yay I'm jumping in
front of the grenade no gets in your
hair no they're not again so and then
I'll stop it in if it gets in your hair
yeah i'm going back to base to say Bobby
did me no because you don't because you
don't even know why the struggles in my
ass I don't know why it's in your yet
because the Viet Cong is attacking right
and I bend over because you're already
[ __ ] me do you already [ __ ] me
right and that's how no I'm not kidding
but what I'm saying is that if you and I
are in war for 10 years and then we were
like leaving like going back to the
states that we're gonna separate right
we would give each other a pound pound
we wouldn't do what it's a lot on and it
was it was close you're very clear it is
ok right their fingers for anything yeah
so you're not and you were you were
denying that they were gay but now
what's your opinion kalila originally I
was like look their European you know
they get touched me or they play touch
by the lodge right but then now I have a
real fury in place oh here we go so both
gerard piqué and Zlatan have been with a
woman for a long time but both of their
women are 10 years approximately 10
years older than them only women who are
women are older the moon yeah so so slot
x wife it's like 46 and shakira is about
37 so very pk's what like a 29-28
there's in like knives for those anyways
my theory is this only older women would
really allow for a sexual fluidity in
their marriage mean to say that I think
that only old it comes with age to kind
of be a little bit more understanding of
your man's sexuality at suppose like
they were both bisexual I bet you those
two women who would be okay with it like
I did
if in my 20s I wouldn't want to be with
a guy who was bisexual but now that I'm
in my 30s I'd wouldn't bother me so
Bobby's bisexuality does not bother I'm
Damascus you know there's no that's
probably [ __ ] what I just wonder why
not i said i'm not against air oh yeah
that makes some sense to me but you guys
are playing good now huh yeah so we
target liverpool you I know but that was
still like you know you thought I
thought you guys will lose you do yeah I
did because it was like what 85th minute
yeah and then a lot on gets a head out
header burnt tires head and it shows the
old menu fighting spirits right and then
we almost kind of want it yeah you guys
almost kind of want it and um and I
thought that their goal was [ __ ]
there's a penalty yeah [ __ ] yeah and
park by my stuff they got lucky me to go
but I mean I'm just saying that pause ba
I don't think who do you think that that
was a handball no I don't think was
intentional yeah that's how yeah and
that's how they get going here but you
know it just is what it is yeah they
want to say our goal was offsides yeah
you know right but and I was actually
rooting for you guys are you were yeah
because um I want Liverpool to start
losing oh yeah because so you because
they Pat where are you guys now woman
why for oh yeah but man city did you see
that game every claim Peppa's pep [ __ ]
up Wow well I'm if I told you this on
the podcast he this is the worst
personnel he's ever had to coach at
Bossa he had the best in the league
right at Bayern I professionally yeah he
came to a team that has no defenders and
no defensive midfielders and and and his
team his personnel are not the best
players in the league he has four good
place yeah he has a guerra Aguero
sterling DeBruyn and David Silva yeah
and so that I may Allah sometimes y'all
your tour is it I did
the sale david silva daba daba da [ __ ]
my European that's right that time I
apologize noting I apologize ok am I
thank you everybody in your inner city
here and I might my bad right people
only I got it you know right oh yeah 13
you got a shitty team no offense right
you're right i mean you think clichy and
sonia and those guys are bad too I just
think even with clichy and Sonia you
have no defensive midfielder right as
well you do but he's he's out for like
three games that's why offer an Andy
know if I got a red card every area and
then Artyom ND and Johnstone's is
probably too young yeah he should
probably be a defensive midfielder yeah
boy yeah boy is out of the part of the
four or no no good lor yeah but he
lumbered sometimes that's right it
doesn't track that doesn't track back
yeah and talk back on the Davies goal
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah right that my fan I
live under this podcast go we don't talk
about my we have a lot of sense I'll
just tell you I'm gonna talk about what
I want to talk about hey I like [ __ ]
talk about what I want to talk about
another [ __ ] edited all right I was
gonna do what I'm gonna do all right and
I love everybody I want people to have a
good time right but I'm no longer gonna
have that in my head just to I'm just
love this venting from my own soul I
just can't believe leicester city is
doing this shitty I mean I guess you
can't believe it but then you sort of
feel bad that you know then you really
believe that it was a fluke it was a
fluke but you when you when you look how
they play now you're like goddamn renew
you was a good coach last year right
yeah and then you give him credit for
for the like it wasn't impossible win
and this is who they really are ok yeah
when you have a dream attached to
something and and the whole country and
the world is praying for something to
happen we kind of manifested them right
I really believe in manifestation yeah
me too and so um but now they won the
league
now the rest of the world [ __ ] it what
now the regular people win right and um
now they're just terrible yeah not great
and Jamie have already should assign
with Arsenal and you know you know I had
like some Irish dude on the podcast
today and and we realized something like
I like this yeah yeah like where we're
island way from Ireland yeah but they
they're in town yeah but are they from
Ireland or they just Norfolk from
Ireland also they actually have that
reaction yeah yeah yeah and one of them
was like like and and somebody else said
you said I don't know who said that
Wenger doesn't like certain
personalities on his side yeah not
anymore he used to like the tough guys
yeah but the team is a little awesomes a
little soft and you guys could assign
Conte yeah and and conti went to a team
that was 10th in the league last year
yes post a team that was you guys second
inning League last year yeah I wanker
should have pursued him more and had a
better chance of getting I mean that's
what you guys need I Avengers made a lot
of mistakes yeah I mean he could have
signed back in the day you remember rich
nor over the club do you think he was
like a liability I don't know but it was
my goal do we go no but this is when ear
emerged it was young no this is like
when he was 18 or 19 you know we could
assign them all right and um also it
lets you sanchez his behavior this
weekend did you see that yeah but I acts
another awesome friend of mine yeah you
know he's he's a gunner for life and
yeah me too and he was like you just
upset that he came out the game no no
something else let's hear this right now
tell me we're winning 4-0 mm-hmm Danny
Welbeck has been hurt for a very long
time as you know when somebody's injured
for that long and they get healthy they
need the playing time right right so van
gurgles were up 40 I'm going to take the
stars off and Alexis Sanchez literally
started almost crying because he got
substituted for a friend of his who's a
teammate who needs to plank plank on
and then at one point he's on the bench
and he has his jacket over his face and
he's like doesn't want the cameras to
see him because he got adopted out it is
so dramatic and [ __ ] and [ __ ] dumb
be a [ __ ] man and be a good dude all
right now that makes sense but why did
he do it though why was he being
dramatic because he's always like that
like it's a fact what he's like that
though passionate yeah he's okay is that
passion sure right but there's also
there's a there's a line it make it your
question does make me wonder like yeah
like all right why is he doing that yeah
he's he's making it uncomfortable for
the [ __ ] team right he makes it all
about himself like he's you know it's
like all of a sudden now all the
newspaper sites on the news is all about
him acting like a [ __ ] baby right and
it shouldn't have been about that it
should have been about how we won 4-0 in
how I'm Danny Welbeck is healthy and be
positive but you have to be able to
argue to that it's at the same intense
competitive spirit what makes him a baby
also makes him Alexei Sanchez right no
yes i think so i think he's probably
been versus if he's one of the
hardest-working he is honest here if the
rest of your team like if the members of
the team like had the passion that he
had you guys to be top of the table I
don't know man I think I guy keeps
running man that's that's not jilla t
it's like it like I'm Nigel II hit what
it called struck conditioning no let me
say this right now if I was on Arsenal
team the way I am now and trust me i
will have the passion and if you don't
have the don't have the ability oh no I
they go if there was like a machine that
you can attach to me and Alexei and who
has more passion I think might even be
good to go above it yeah no it wasn't in
terms of passion you've never find mr.
passion you've never played Captain
ratchet you don't [ __ ] know that
about me telling him in high school do I
attach the job my eyes girls geared up I
crumble there yeah have you played it a
ball sport ever in your life yes [ __ ] I
played ball for [ __ ] all right tennis
is not a ball go to bed bored
I have and you know I have yeah i was on
the high school pageant here I mean
you're passionate now carry here yeah
yeah I'm passionate i don't have the
conditioning right so exciting what if I
believe Drew's just as passionate no
really that scorpion Kick enough passion
you're very well talk about Steve Harvey
why because o meeting from know him
saying that Asian men are incapable what
do you say that last week you did yeah I
mean see what happens when you meet with
Trump yeah a lot of people believe and
this is a cultural thing that's in a
miracle american cultural thing where
they believe that we're not hands or sex
symbols males the women i have always
you know asian women have always been
like fetishized and put on a pedestal
but a varnan by auto races yeah yeah by
wife you know generally and um i'll give
you an example like when that delicious
between steel we've talked about on the
podcast Evian's relationship in the show
walking dead wood that white chick
magnet with maggie right and then ran
secret said what he said oh yeah what is
wrong he said I don't believe that they
should be Maggie's kind of asian though
she's white completely yes you play from
the funk please buzz greatest actor you
know you are those guys that if a white
chick is getting asian guy used a
location hahahaha you want it no no I
are those guys you're one of those guys
you guys I'm you before so you can't
accept it you can't accept it so in your
head you cyclotron all right now so her
eyes aren't a little as ya know nothing
agent about or do nothing yeah I don't
lie I'm not black but you're one of the
if it 60 Martin's kind of black Oh
yeah the real world even Bowie's uh
David Bowie's black because dating you
know I belt yeah yeah she's not Asian
baby boys good oh I don't feel example
anyways right Ryan Seacrest basically
said that you know it does a lot it
doesn't really it wouldn't really have
to deal and it isn't bite in the
apocalypse only time you could buy you
could buy any time but if you are a
skeptic yeah yeah yeahs you under 12
guys left yeah the odds are she she's
not easy when I think is like I see her
date in her dad you know but you know
even or no right secret trouble is he
should probably what vaginas before she
dated like I'll go lesbian I mean said
some white dude they can't accept it but
you know asian dude they're cool white
chick sorry I was one of them there you
go yeah i mean not we've he's done it
what what did ya wait what you like this
like what yeah i was really hard oh man
i do exactly good oh [ __ ] over white
dude you just [ __ ] her how did you
know I your day long way whatever video
Steve Harvey no you're not you look at
my my like this yeah that's [ __ ]
we're doing and we're gonna [ __ ] and
talk about that in a second yeah he
wrote a book on how to date a white
woman a practical guide for Asian men do
you Hari he didn't write that I think
someone else did and he was like talked
about yeah and he was like if that was a
book or it would be one page long do you
date asian men and their response would
be no and he went on to say oh he said
you like Asian men I don't live in like
Chinese food he said I don't eat what I
can't pronounce a bargain there's magic
for me that's attention that doesn't
bother me practice sometimes Steve
Harvey like does this way if you just
say ignorant things it sounds funny and
that's yeah yeah yeah even when he is on
family feud which I watches bloopers and
I think it's very funny very funny very
funny onsite manager and some of the
jokes are like sometimes a little
you know hacking but he has to improvise
within you know a clean way right so I I
forgive him for that though he is a
comedian so I'm gonna give him that but
aside from him there is a lot of people
that believe that and it's got to stop
well let me ask you a question yeah like
do Asian dudes go after other races yeah
yeah last night I did the improv and it
and a tiger raving fan so sit in the
front row asian dude was dating a white
girl I see it in my show also happens so
that may be in my shows there did they
just come out right but it's like you
know um I see it all the time but what
bothers me about about that is that I
have Asian female friends who were
offended by the fact who don't like the
fact that Asian men see dating a white
woman as a step above dating them oh
that's ballsy you say that a lot oh you
won the lottery you're dating a white
woman not in the lottery in terms of
like what you got it's in terms of like
arm socially right like it's because
it's such a it's a little harder it
happens in the black community why it's
a little harder I feel the same way so
it there is a sense of like oh [ __ ] I'm
you know mean I'm cueing big game here I
just shoot like coyotes and now running
back yeah yeah I've got back and I ought
to turn back now i am with my hands yeah
there is a sense of that like when you
went when I was 24 and I was with
Jennifer field and she was this girl
that lived by the beach and get like
dolphin tattoos which is so [ __ ]
gross but on and um honoring a later
[ __ ] I was in her closet and her mom
was home oh Sh I was eating her [ __ ] in
the closet closet yeah yeah you know
crazy and um but and I looked at her
like a little because if I could see
through those you know that the darkness
were paying for white days yeah it's the
unlikeliness that makes it feel like
again or maybe this is real good with in
like four months later we're gone done
earlier yeah because her in size wasn't
right with my inside woodiwoodi be by
that didn't know she didn't have a penis
is a don't like not into ssible organs
[ __ ] I was talking about like our
beliefs and our values and it sound like
some to anatomical is not a physical
yeah it's not what was it we were okay
it wasn't physical as dog just an okay
day I just can't the inauguration to is
really making me nervous not nervous
beef laughs oh they have three dogs not
what's a band playing three doors down
three doors down he'll be read it'll be
down yeah and some girl Rockets half of
them a 16 year old white girl a six year
old white girl who's like a opera singer
whatever yeah and that's it I know I
thought that's what about all the roof
springs feel16 cover band rubber bands
yeah that's hilarious and they were
build their built in the front page of
it oh sure like Obama can get Bruce
spring green in the actual the a/c guy
Obama got Eddie Vetter to warm up the
crowd in his farewell speech not even
televised early just charming up the
crowd and there is something about I'm
sorry I'm going to say this I don't want
to talk about politics on my show and we
we treated it on the election day was
really upsetting and I'm gonna cried and
stuff like that prod arm I try not to
talk about it but there is something to
say that the a-list stars of the world
won't play his inauguration what about
crying at any western guys no not yet
elite though is he the elite of that
tell bikini this real old school country
ability is not that he's who's the
biggest country where like Elton I mean
yeah you have like she'll plan you have
like there's a lot of guys I think we're
way bigger than Toby Keith now yeah but
who probably wouldn't play just because
it's a little bit too and fun if it was
Toby Keith and five other name ass I
feel like yeah he's but if toby keith is
the gun
I love your whole inauguration it's sad
yeah and it's pitiful I mean what about
all these red state musicians no yeah
but like a look at the guy like Dixie
Chicks not at all and every one of them
there's a lot of them that also they
don't want to get I'm sure there are
people that want to but they know the
content we're not a good look oh yeah
and there's something to that that like
what so why isn't a good look let's
explore that because he is misogynistic
a little racist he caters to white
nationalists and there's a lot of things
that you know me he is in cahoots with
Putin there's [ __ ] some [ __ ] that we
don't even know about this happening so
it's like their reputations will be on
the line and to me it's that's just
embarrassing to have that as our [ __ ]
president it's Jennifer Holliday still
going to do yeah and she and she needs
the gig she does yeah I was last time
you had to Jennifer I know you can't but
I thought she was dead son you get to be
back out of that thing roblin great move
though great PR move to actually accept
and then Oh Holly's alive I should and
then that DG you had never heard of was
it oh the guy in Johnny Ravi drums yeah
he's playing yeah and he's like you know
me in some like specific beats like
clubs that he's doing they have a moat
around like that and it's like we've
never heard of him that's Steve I dokie
yeah Bobby know this guy dunno and it's
just it's so embarrassing steve aoki
cover band so Bobby asked me this
question yesterday now if you were
invited to sit front row at the
inauguration would you go what are ya
you get your you're like gonna be right
next to trump they just want you there
nobody knows me like that so I could go
and then write a set about it yeah I me
but I but if I'm Steve Harvey I don't
think I would have met with him the
other day from yeah that is yeah yeah I
wouldn't yeah I just
I'm Joe general of the pant camera would
pan like pan across and then see like
just might you know yeah I would be
really i was i would need for the sake
of like a viral clip or if i was doing
yeah i don't think i could go cuz i
would I was afraid you would know I
wouldn't even know who to talk to though
I don't know any of that what if you ask
you to emcee the inauguration the
president ugh there's no what's the
price what's your price and what's your
price how much money would you have to
sweetie I'm sayin I've turned down gigs
that were better for me for ya for good
money so yeah I definitely wouldn't do
that yes over here you're a man of
integrity Bobby well i don't know i i've
been offered to two and good a kind of
it I don't do it I want to do it it's
good luck I don't care I don't want to
go i'm kind of pic you anyway yeah i
mean i only do comedy clubs that are
like a list a rooms and I know that the
conditions are going to be honest right
for me and I'm 22 lazy lazy and the [ __ ]
i would say get me oh yeah I wouldn't
yes five minutes into that said that's
not true I mean I find you to be um not
offensive at all on your ass oh no
really i look at your act I know you're
saying would you say things right that
are I guess but to me I think those
things right oh maybe to me that they're
not arguing you mean I think that what
those people would like someone like
Bryan Holtzman who I love watching Ryan
he says things sometimes their life oh
you know but not you know and also if
you were that offensive you wouldn't be
playing any of the clubs in LA I don't
think because yeah I think um but people
people i know i do run into people that
do you think I'm offenses what yeah yeah
cool some audiences might like this is
this is like me what I'm saying I would
like it to be normal yeah but it's not
to some people yeah and it just is
because they have phony values and I'm
going to full of [ __ ] it was funny that
you say that because it's like
there are some bits that i do I
literally think that they're so funny
but I can when I tell them on stage
sometimes I know that the audience just
completely hates it and uncomfortable
like that joke about Monica and David
that I do about down syndrome people
they keep making love how they have to
make it up make up the moves they touch
budget for like three minutes and
something that yeah I mean some things
like that right and I'm telling it I'm
ban over touching the but with the other
guy right and I'm looking at the
audience like making a face going come
on right and I can tell that they're
really just like not I think people me
here like the inauguration I'd pay you
to do the Noghri evening yeah Oh that'd
be great if they said it you can do any
jokes that you want all my gyno we were
doing yeah would you do it like
co-headline with me 10 minutes a penis
Noir with bomb I know but it'd be so fun
everyone laughs on vacations together I
would sit there like Indian cell
watching yourself right and everyone
people boo you and me just laughing I
think that'd be great to pitch this idea
i think it's do it oh yeah I hope it's
do it I just know where could talk about
here I want to do it but that would be
so scared you know scared i'd be yeah
I'd be terrified I mean him and I back
there going you open you oh yeah I'm you
prefer I did a gig with a Mike Young and
Mike Young set it up it was in Venice
you don't mind young yeah right and it
was on a rooftop in this like beach
house in Venice and they had a mic and
speakers on the roof and then below
right below there's a pool party just
during the day to write and there was
hundreds hundreds of people it was a DJ
and then they go and I was supposed to
go first and then Mike Young was
supposed to go second yes so I go up and
I what's up and they turned the music up
and everyone's kind of looking up at me
and then I do myself bombing so [ __ ]
hard and it anyway the next guy um he's
a friend of mine he actually told me to
do this gig Mike young and I turn around
he had left work oh he left the [ __ ]
game hi yeah and I just talked to him
for a year up I mean I was so livid that
like number
you set it up right number two you leave
me did you get paid because you yeah I
don't remember I don't remember but like
that was the biggest betrayal I've
everything got a smoker yeah it's [ __ ]
up yeah I did a gig like that at
Paramount Jamie Masada set it up yeah
yeah so it's like yeah my studios at the
studio on a Saturday night all mine like
everybody's on the lot they have like an
outside like dinner party yes and so the
stage is here yeah there's a huge
fountain yeah in the in the middle yeah
and there's a space yeah which is a
dance floor and then people back am
eating Sunaina I got those yeah then
there's like a five comics yeah so who
are they can be the color remember their
name okay I'll try to heard of them
before yeah yeah who shows them all okay
I bet Jerry bed nap was one of them okay
I think me and him will last all right
and then somebody goes up bombs Itza he
hide nothing during the other person up
bombs eats it nothing then the third
person goes up and I think I'm next yeah
that person bomb beat it nothing yeah
and then the lady who Jamie made the
show it comes up to me and Gary and said
this isn't working out here's your
paychecks we're going to end the show
right here oh wow and then then the
other guys came over oh yeah and was
like yeah so what we don't you are you
got people up your pain but all I had to
do we just hang out and eat oh yeah and
then we our careers weren't ruined but
yeah paramount lot industry oh and I had
to like go home and hope everybody will
forget oh my house at work I was like
the great stopping point for the show I
was Jamie there no he was no of course
he is there and I wasn't mad at him
after I money we got three but watching
the three commas you're probably scared
like I way we're gonna do what am I
gonna yeah yeah yeah for sure it wasn't
it wasn't I don't understand why people
do die like do birthday parties it's
like the country club yeah I had
one summer Oh Mike how do you wrangle
people and be like everybody know who
know folk i get about it and I Michael
and I know it was a contract i'll do a
country club all right i'm like a
millionaire right guys I look you can
you do comedy might was a bachelor party
one with everybody and birthday with the
birthday so I show up really naughty
play it really nice if you are dancing
you know you know see no season or just
dancing right and all this all right
comedy and I go to Gilbert I couldn't go
on [ __ ] open he didn't even do
stand-up at the time I met it
bullshitting people who don't care right
yeah how was good it was bad it was like
wrangling cattle to her though she was
like to think come closer come this way
yeah calm down or do something yeah it
was great for me I was just cry laughing
in the back and then I went up and I
don't know what the [ __ ] I did but you
didn't do your full set you got naked I
got naked right away quick you cookin
clothes not like really quick because
the money was so good right right I had
to do something I couldn't say are
really nice so nice I couldn't say I
don't want to do it you can keep the
morning right because he was such easy
money or I had to do what I'm sorry to
do 10 chicken minute earlier 40 minutes
bad i don't remember i know you blocked
it out are you block it out hey I know
how to do it were like I just think
going well so I just go to the easiest
jokes that I have mm-hmm the switches
all right so much jokes I don't even
tell anymore really and then you go
right into getting naked and then its
usual [ __ ] out of everybody got yeah you
shut the [ __ ] everybody I were I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened and then you
run and grab dinner and run out there
it's were much robbery yeah when I when
I was in New York like we used to do
clubs a lot like dance clothes and talk
to music yeah why not yeah and people
gather around each other and it's like
what what like I was a different comic
in New York to write a lot louder your
dreadlock yeah when I you just like yell
everything just to get the audience's
attention right and and then keep it you
know and then like at least scare them
into now hoechlin yeah employee that you
say that because
I know that Joe was Rogan when he was in
Boston he wasn't doing clubs he was like
doing like bars and stuff like that and
he learned to really like techniques to
get an audience on his side one of them
was which I had never heard at the time
was you instead of going that way right
you go the opposite where you start kind
of talking solidly yeah so that then
people kind of stopped talking to still
listen to what you're saying and which
is an interesting you would think that
your gut instinct would be to go and
talk over them right but he told me that
right and I know a lot of comas that
started in the East Coast that started
with more of an aggressive style because
that's the conditions that they were in
running our own words i started in san
diego dnes at yeah we had it from you
yeah but I did learn that technique
though like like when I do shows in
England yeah like it's like a bar
culture and if you yell they'll talk
louder so they can hear themselves talk
yeah so the you raised a raise you raise
if you speak low then they'll be aware
and conscious of how loud they're
speaking and they'll take it down lawman
could get people right and it's like it
feels like the weirdest thing to do but
it does work yeah yeah I ever played
South Africa no I never I wanted to go I
didn't okay and when I flew in there
like the lady that was in charge of the
festival said was only you know that and
I'd never heard of this before Asians on
third-class citizens and some time to
write people oh yeah we should be good
night oh I've never heard of that before
yeah so so I'm telling you right now
like if we play 2006 leaders okay and I
did 30 show and the line it was good it
was like Pablo Francisco me Kira stefana
[ __ ] I think she's very funny sousou's
maybe I shouldn't matter honey yeah and
Ryan stout mo Mandel and um Kevin Allen
Trevor Noah and but is it before Trevor
Noah Trevor Noah and um I killed because
they hurry because they were scared
because I was Asian all right so they
put me up first or second which was to
me like Lars that's great okay you know
and I would go to care like just I just
because that you'll do 10 minutes sir so
I'll just condense everything just you
know kill and then we would do meet and
greets afterwards and in front of like
just regular people that's paid like
extra you know before the bonus pack is
he anything like the VIP and not one
time did anyone look at me and say we
think you're funny all right I would be
in front of everyone and everyone would
get compliments and I would just sit
there and not one well part of South
Africa with this that was enjoy a burger
so what color was the audience that p
paid for the vm ID but no they're nice
people upstage I just didn't get any
compliments on are you exaggerate miss
could not honor I'm glad I'm glad in it
that I'm glad I challenged me in that
way now because now you get to see how
are you how are you know how you get to
see what I had to do was here is welcome
surprise here yeah yo yo yo man where I
will use in Australian are you sure
you're not you're not angry never k
something do it right do I call this
person do right and I live life and
experiencing right my soul my senses and
I perceive it in the most honest way and
I related in the most honest way and for
you to challenge me like that in front
of my other hat so you've never been a
little neurotic yes uh you're saying
yeah yeah yeah I'm neurotic he creates
problems in his mom yeah sometimes yeah
yeah whoa man that's a bag set that our
plans
you by the way don't ever backup plan B
I'm planet he's right about that you're
right but I I'm neurotic yeah so that's
what i end up asking if yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeahs factor my neuroses yes okay
let me say something right now no last
night I did the improv I was just all
weekend that they were running problem
right and I know I know that I'm good I
no no my show was good and I know that
when people say man that was a great
show I I go yeah I know I really
genuinely know all right there are times
it when you see me in the original room
where where I am a little neurotic
because you're compete like it's more of
a competition learn there's a lot of
comics there you don't want to you know
you just want to say phase right but in
this [ __ ] circumstance or
self-supporting a couple right is it a
real litigated [ __ ] thing man all
right so [ __ ] a heavy [ __ ] so I can't
ask you a question you can ask me
anything about about if the roses came
into play all right now maybe want to
factor a little bit but my point is my
man you right I'll change okay sorry
miss alive it happened I never been shut
up yeah I got [ __ ] every show guys
funny damn it no I really did experience
that and I got mugged there to get the
[ __ ] yeah I got margin ashore Wow
again what happened I walked out on my
hotel room at like 3pm and you knew who
ian bag is yeah yeah Ian bag goes I'm
gonna go across the street to get
somebody like a cigarette room whatever
he was getting mmm she wants a got
straight like okay I'll stay here and
this is it like a five-star hotel all
right it is in cape town now mm-hmm hold
a sudden I'm just on the ground oh shoot
right and in the hotel no I'll right
outside the hotel
outside when tours for walking on
whatever two guys pull me down onto my
belly and one guy has his knee on my
spine and the rifling through my pocket
that is crazy oh look do you like the
story no no your honor you hear analyzer
know why this is no no there with the
mill road why mr. nobody are you asking
me why didn't you laugh like that
because it's funny Oh what stop it's
hilarious why why because you're alive
when you're here for tell the story oh
that's literal but but that is bananas
now now here's your day yeah ya like
like I heard about South Africa and I
heard that they assign you like that
people go with you anywhere like
bodyguards yay did you guys have him no
I'm not so I know I memorized you got
robbed we had this guy who was in charge
like The Bodyguard of the whole group
that's not enough but during the day you
know you just figure and I think they
figured they told us what streets not to
go down what not all right but in the
area that we are in general and then it
was to Africans that black eyes that
dinner right and then you can't go to
please because you're Asian they're not
gonna believe you or not they're not
only that all right not only that it's
like how do you just you know me like in
a second how do you describe right right
you're on your hair to the latter eyes
on you you're on your stomach hahaha
yeah yeah so what they take my
blackberry and some cash and no one I
came to your rescue and then people were
just walking by watching this yeah and
then hey yo Halpern yeah that Ian ran
across the street he saw them yeah I
don't think he does another thing I have
with him I think he took a little too
long ago they wanna think that he
watched the same whole thing is over and
that he slowly walked away my young do
yeah you might come to me and then he
was like whatever I go you saw what
happened
canadians after yeah or yeah you don't
expect a Canadian to get involved in
that oh no way but you know give a big
hug no yeah but uh one time right we are
being some friends I I drove my car to
Manhattan to meet up with some other
comics all right and uh so I go meet
them and we do a show so now i'm going
to give everybody a ride back in my car
when we get to my car there's somebody
sitting in the car what really yeah see
how I just left there right that's funny
so you know in your mind does crazy
things like when they held you down on
the ground what was flashing through
your mind so many things / through my
mind in like one instant it was crazy
you don't know I've been in situations
like that before in terms of like like a
[ __ ] up situation and you literally go
I ki I can't believe doesn't happen a
real like a real yeah yeah cuz I'd
redolence long to your body yeah cuz I
have a friend named Roger and all do and
I was like oh we all have a rock I like
oh that's Roger sitting in the car he
just met me there and it's probably him
in the car but I'm like then I like how
to [ __ ] with Roger know where you parked
yeah why Roger be in your how did he get
in your car yeah yeah my mind tried to
smooth the whole [ __ ] up immediately and
I and then I got nada a stranger in your
car holy [ __ ] the next three of us you
didn't lock it it was locked oh there's
three of us and we rolled up on the dude
yeah and then talent he's taller [ __ ]
that's his name yeah it's in the talent
yeah the common from New York and uh you
know he rolls up rose he goes like what
like now we surround the car and then
sounds like a man lying down the window
so he does this like one wine ya like
like is it like it was an old car yet
the dual wind I mean it was a really old
Soviet yay Sony's like it can I help you
like it's his car and I minute raising
yeah he's not crazy just caught
then counts like what are you doing in
cars I didn't take nothing some towns
like wind the window all the way down so
then he does and in town of the
collection punches him and this aren't
takes him so that he can't do anything
and then we open the door and we take
him out and then we beat him up a little
bit did you really yeah you kicked out
but I held him it was like it was like
the movies like one guy holds one arm
yeah everybody be the most and then we
took his [ __ ] is raw way dessert we
totally deserve it you Robert feather
key that could open any car door and I
took don't have relatively it's like
it's like a bunch of GM keys and just
keys that can open anything so he didn't
break my door that's the first time my
car but got broken into and the door
handle wasn't ripped ah so you just he
just walked into that mouth Wow and we
just took his key so I can call the cops
nah right we don't snatch the street
just yeah yeah yeah yeah I never who was
he gonna complain to you I and then
somebody's car it's crazy yeah it's some
lady go into your car while you were
invited yeah two weeks cause that rotten
about saw write it in the parking lot
and then I just put the stick shut the
car and I in my peripheral I know
there's someone else in the car and then
look over and there's like a white
homeless lady thank you goes Dianna Cahn
yeah well I like something crazy like
doesn't speak English I am by the way I
got magana right back at her yeah that's
how I did it and then she started on my
I go by and I do I [ __ ] you get out I
could get out her and she left and she
just walked on how did you get in your
car well I was just like sitting there i
think i was playing like um city
everybody in the car i was in the city
is slicing city uh-huh and I heard the
door open and then I look over and then
she was a homeless he just wanted her I
don't know her [ __ ] living
circumstances [ __ ] Gilbert all right
[ __ ] together
I'd be a lot of delivers you you look
like you lost weight since last week
ashamed you they body shame me otherwise
didn't eat like lunch the twine Ansley
well he used to be like 250 pounds you
know what that stereotype Asians have
flat faces you're definitely been there
11 I mean I just look at your faces now
holy [ __ ] like ihop wide like a panic
like a picture yeah it was like a pet
you know it's like those German lemon
pancakes is Ali you hardly have any
dimension to so I wouldn't yeah but
yours is longer a demented was right
it's fine so sorry I'm not like that so
on the inauguration and then that's it
that's our society our society is it's
fine it's gonna win it with four years
oh yeah we good we can ride that on
ourselves right okay hopefully another
four years possibly there's no one I
don't think that that that I'd be
shocked but the Republicans going to
push and try to get it yeah they just I
just don't understand how you can take
insurance away from 30 million people
well not replace it I saw some today so
he's going to make insurance for
everybody and make it cheaper well out
of its socket I don't know no no you
know it just probably don't reason why
the Obamacare is the way it is is
because that was the really the only way
they could have done it really for it to
get passed I think right exactly it's
like it's not like they were helping it
yeah to work better for the opposition
against your thing so you have to make
compromises and all that stuff and then
act like this is original plan right leg
one yeah i feel ya I mean the original
plan we want to be like Canada and
England where every single person gets
free health care right I think that's
everyone there are all back to their
form of universal health care to not as
none of no form of unifor universal
health care is without cracks but you
know Obamacare is so brand-new and they
did have to make a lot of concessions
because all the Republicans were against
them right off the bat right on his
first day of being you know president
but i think you know you have to also
admit
that obamacare has deep deep cracks
there's a lot of things wrong with it
like what I mean for instance you know
for me somebody who goes in and out of
the emergency room a lot I wasn't even
able to see or to have a bed in the
emergency room because we don't even
have the infrastructure to support that
many people having or being insured it's
simple as that we're like not no I'm
just saying just a simple simple
invitation no no but that's just one of
the many things but it is a great place
to start and I don't think that you
should get rid of something that was
headed in the right direction to fix it
whatever yeah you fix it your kitchen
yeah yeah I'm all for fixing it yeah all
right but I'm not also or they don't
want him to have the credit like the
Republicans while Obama's in office
they'd rather destroy the country just
to make him look bad then have a good
country yeah and that's on patreon yeah
i was watching the special on the Obama
legacy and as he was giving his
inauguration speech they were all in
like the top Republicans were all in a
room together and vowing to make sure
that they block him at every single
point how does along the way yeah
exactly our helpers made rally are we
the [ __ ] plane come down no don't
help him pilot you know nothing to and I
realized that gun laws in this country
on never than a change because if Sandy
Hook didn't change it nothing well it's
little kids getting shot didn't change
gun rights in the gun laws in this
country nothing's gonna change it do you
believe that that happened yeah I
believe it yeah i was in connecticut
that weekend oh really yeah you were
yeah I to show you know that Casino
Foxwoods oh I hate that room this is my
[ __ ] a general yeah it's just the
worst room that mall is a guy in a
ravine yeah but it's big right yeah and
oh I hate it you did with it or the club
their zombie come over to the club I did
the common core to but uh our doctor I
got there thursday and you know you
travel to the east coast you
disorientated so the Thursday show had
like it's all usually the weakest show
of the of the weekend so I had like 40
people there you know and and they were
good crowd so then I go to sleep you
know first you know the owners are cool
we've been bowling we had fun that night
I go to sleep I wake up and boom the
shooting it was like I like God all
right yeah so then so then it took a
while to rip for me to realize oh [ __ ]
i'm in Connecticut and this place is
closed like how close was it I don't
know but you know Connecticut Celtic the
most you know lie yeah yeah yeah because
you know when you're going to talk to a
casino you're not leaving for the entire
weekend and everything you need is there
why Jim any I remember that yeah then
you feel disorientated and you don't
even realize [ __ ] i'm in Connecticut
yeah and then the show thursday that i
thought was going to be the lightest
show of the weekend became the most
packed shoulder week ago I so people
were just so affected by at by it yeah
they didn't come out I had like 10
people are oh my god and then you
couldn't mention it either yeah cuz I
didn't know what to say so there's no
way you can that yeah yeah it was the
most worldwide not enough time that
elapsed to even create and even the
remotely careful you know yeah and then
they're like nut cases like like that
believe that it was all the conspiracy I
like what do you call those white flag
yeah so what did it be calling like
white or something robot anyway I where
we are now over an hour we did yeah oh
my god I I went before though I'm not
because we do we wrap it up with
questions huh but before we do with that
even in I want to say this number one
thank you so much for doing my podcast
on my project number two we're [ __ ]
friends 400 when I mean that my dad is
not a gay thing you should let label us
bring her buttons that say [ __ ] friends
for life Rockford's like footprints like
we're not friends for life no we are
friends for life will we [ __ ] no we
don't go basically we do suck
spiritually no no no you got to love him
i bleep up with you today
with each other networks that's what i
meant to let it yeah friend and I don't
think what is that um I when I was in
the 90s 90s maybe early two thousand
whatever i was watching HBO no dodging
uh def Comedy Jam it was I think was bad
boys of comedy it was a bad boys a
comment one of those ideas right and um
I saw Ian go up and he was so funny in
it I literally thought to myself I
wanted Alan I think I want to be around
these types of people you know he was
literally rocker you know no I thought
it was my favorite ok I want to be
around people that are like our killer
you know I mean that also you know he's
jamaican you know there was something
about him that was different and then um
he has no hair anymore but when i met
him the Baldy in years later and I we're
friends and it's like it's really a cool
thing we didn't get your how long you
were born in jamaica and how long did
you live there cloud nine okay oh no no
no one in England I lived in England
totality of the main I don't have to
switch it up I was like 17 oh wow the
cooler yeah you were born England call
this an international man of mystery and
then you would then and then when you
come to the states mouth 17 17 wow what
was that like what the face it's being
like a young black man coming from
England in Jamaica and then too great to
New York yeah long islands little
confusion like you have to refine like
every day you wake up in Jamaica you got
friends everybody speaks the same way as
you everybody has the same culture we
same food yeah then next time you're in
a country and even the black people
don't talk like you don't just like you
I like you and the culture is different
yeah so you gotta catch up and anyway
answer this how long you been um Jamaica
no not to make it was it called the 16
guys are weird budget Aryan oh yeah yeah
yeah you're vegan vegan right
tificate uh maybe like 12 years now you
will not eaten any cookies in any kind
of religion what is wrong laughter ah
like if I went let's go korean BBQ you
can do it no but i went with some
friends the other day and uh like that
looks like a chicken place they were
very tempting it was yes very tempted
'never do that to you what made you a
vegan or choose to be a vegan I just
like when I was a kid like I KFC right
was [ __ ] delicious it was amazing
just chicken period and then somewhere
along the line like and it's like when
your kid you want when you did like when
you it was a special thing k if he was
like we're getting KFC yeah yeah I don't
know if that's because how broke we were
yeah or should I get that yeah right now
church's chicken was good yeah there you
go so I was like when I grow up I'm just
gonna have to have my money I'm gonna
detect a nap KFC and then and I did that
and I thought this doesn't taste the
same yeah and then enough and it wasn't
the ingredients that they change the
actual chicken but they have to make so
much meat for so many people like all
these restaurants around here to get
them food they cheat yeah they put in
hormone to the stuff and I should have
not helped yeah I mean someone even
setting this thing on my phone there's
it's inside a chicken guy right yeah who
he's whistle blowing on the chicken
Department and he's like he's like he
takes the big good reporter into the
chicken coop and he's like this is what
they call free range chicken there's no
cages they're all in here but there's
like a thousand chickens in this room
yeah and that's how they skirt the law
and anyone and they they don't call the
growth hormones or the whatever they
inject or feed it to animals anymore
what they what the FDA says they can't
use they call it something else so they
still feed the chickens like I'm saying
the same thing have found a way to skirt
and then they're the ones that did the
FDA sends them a checklist of things
that they have to comply with and there
that fill it out they don't they don't
know I'm down there and check it out
well then he is a bogus organization
anyway so then they do it and then it's
like it's like us great in our own
papers yeah what we're going to give
ourselves yeah very right yeah but I
want I want I don't want to eat it
anymore you know but I just I can't stop
I mean it's beside you don't have to
stop like sometimes if you don't eat it
as much as you do then that's fine I got
would never tell anybody do this stuff
I'll nah I will be real like well now
you do you used to hate that I'm just
three years now with no I love them can
I eat them dude I don't even believe
over the studio I really I I don't want
to eat them anymore I just I want to be
friends with the animals all of them
yeah although even the chicken yeah I
want to be friends I want life to live
they have every right to live and I eat
the [ __ ] alone and I don't want to
anymore there's nothing nothing even
sways his anything that he does anymore
we watched a documentary called at the
fork and then a Wiccan Wow he watched it
well immediately it was more like
kombucha guy i strangled him yeah at
that moment he feels you know
sympathetic to the animals at that just
exact moment but it's so quick as soon
as the documentaries over is deserting
me a bad person though nicey you know
does that make me a bathrobe no not at
all are you a vegetarian no I just known
each other all gotta be laughing like
what kind of meat do I eat cow no but
I'm very careful about like where i get
if i do eat beef where the beef comes
well that java java basically was a
freshman way i do make exceptions like
you know twice or three times a month we
go to korean food and you know i know
that i don't know where come from but if
i had to shop at myself and very much
i'm very aware of you know making sure
that she's good about the eggs they have
to be free like real free reign
say I'm good about the butter to the
butters I'm really respond yes but it's
really hard to be healthy around it's
tough if I was just tough period because
even when you're trying to be healthy
you don't know if these labels are
corrected just tough manages people
trying to make money out here yeah and
it's so because we are such a big
country it's so hard to regulate
something that like in a country like
Norway they have everything all the
labels are you know Europe and you can
eat all you meet and not feel bad yeah
really yeah but it's easier to operate
in small and it's trickier like that
yeah I'm around yeah I mean let's just
say this okay I'm not going to stop I
just cried I just cry not tried but I'm
not going to stop you shut its here for
the cow you're good you know i feel i
just want i want the world and God to
know that I feel right and I think
that's good enough all right we all just
don't utilize the whole animal here in
the United States like I I McNichol know
the chicken bones good i'm hopeful by we
do an email answer questions ok I'll
helpful advice with Bobby kalila and
Bobby's [ __ ] Fred [ __ ] friend forever
forever I grew up in an alcoholic
abusive household and now as an adult
seems i can only seek out psycho girls
need rescuing a la strippers married
women whose girlfriends etc i have great
times with them in parentheses sex but
has been dangerous at times yikes what
say you oh wise ones I've had sex with
hookers without condom I know we know
this no I'm just saying antenna no
warrants yeah well I've read like I've
literally lived day I stick my dick in
furnaces like I've done dangerous right
yeah yeah like I don't give a [ __ ] right
now I'm in my 20s in my 30s I have put
myself at risk so many times I've been
in many dysfunctional relationships and
um I think that through age and 2 times
0 and I didn't grow up like my dad was
an alcoholic I was my dad used to beat
me too but um I think just over time you
just kind of grow up and go you know
what I kind of know what I need and I
want
and you realize that sex and all that
kind of stuff exists you know me wings
it is amazingly fun and exciting but
it's like you know I'm so silly John
fulfilling and I have something deeper
with kalila you know and um that's the
route I've taken you know and it's a
help you this guy's question is why is
he doesn't understand why you might if
he was a therapy and you know any chance
would work on himself that he might
result him he's got to work on it a
young man is 20 is like why not like bet
that's your time to actually make all
the mistakes and you know seek out
different types of people from all walks
of life you should expose yourself to us
many types of women as possible you
can't just you know be 21 and be like
I'm looking for the perfect girl no you
should date as many shitty people or you
know as much as you can just and it's
the only way to eventually figure out
what exactly what you want all right and
I figure I both of your hands is all
right just be careful being not careful
yeah do that Ben yeah give me another
question yeah hello tiger balm 24 year
old guy that has zero game the Asian
version of pd that's George over this is
the version of you well I I am looking
at that t-shirt now for the first time
is not going to help you get [ __ ] but
I have the great cornholio all right
I've been dating my first girlfriend for
six months now and she is a handful
she's ungrateful and appreciative that
selfish and at times I did it but I
still love her that's it I however am a
[ __ ] sweetheart I don't have I don't
have the guts to tell that she needs to
calm down and just be nice to me for
once how do I approach this one we just
have to bite your tongue I just go
through fun with the [ __ ] that we go
through my [ __ ] foot down otherwise i
go to you get your ass wipe we have said
in bed wine bucket who watch my ass
my [ __ ] I want my own [ __ ] finger
all managed that you have to deal with
uh so basically get yourself an Asian
woman well you just have to accept it
and just pray and not snap and just go
that you're you know that you're the
good one I'm here the good you know that
you're the good one to you you know that
she's acting the way she's acting right
and you just have to accept that but
there's nothing you can change about her
that's the way she is I love how it's
just impossible to believe that the
woman is actually the same person in the
relationship is that so hard to believe
what are you getting angry for me and I
just responded today with that I I don't
I deal with you're gonna do with nothing
to do [ __ ] I never [ __ ] a dude if we
had a reason and also on top of that
[ __ ] you that I'm just saying that has
nothing to do with our relationship I'm
George responding to his thing all right
so I'm just saying in your situation I
know that your girl is acting insane and
homicidally and like unreasonable and
you have to just kind of go swallow it
and go dad to hear I say man up keller
give us some warning and if you don't
respond to them but that's the thing is
I don't want her though yeah that's also
a nicely hey you know hey you know Anna
Anna and I haven't always been good at
like communicating but this is a great
opportunity to communicate yeah you know
and and like say hey man this is not
fair you know this is [ __ ] up and she
may or may not respond and like why are
you dating somebody doesn't care anyway
also don't have been beat me in Edwards
because I'll tell you why look right
this guy's a [ __ ] machine what that's
what I've been told well you hate I'm
just saying you I'm just saying varlam
let me just say this right now I I want
to say something to you right Miley I
like this girl right now well I'm not
gonna be your name I was in it where
she's young very pretty right and to any
normal guy your age cuz you're 50 what
all right I don't know much she's 19
you're kidding what would you be like ah
nah you're crazy and I be like so great
when you don't graduate I'd be like oh
yeah you sure nobody came up to you in
that show and south all I'm saying is
that he's not the right guy to get you
know advice from I don't know like like
how far I mean how how far you'll never
be that will never be a 50 year old
[ __ ] and sitting here process how is
the machined understand how far is is is
he going to be a busy unhappy how old is
he first of all we're going to know the
age bro blister agent nighttime people
my thing is 24 times like oh but I'm in
a sweetheart but but both girls around
that age I like that so you could get
another one he now would be like there's
that right and how come he doesn't get
his head bitten off what do you mean
most women that age are like yeah cuz I
was awesome yes we're raging alcoholics
at that age we just want to [ __ ] and
everyone well for someone you know it
sometimes they don't go a lot of it
anyway so uh you know let me go see is
ass that's great no I'm suited for time
no so I think we're very blessed to have
Ian Ian here and my friend and we keep
saying they're like if you're a girl
about so [ __ ] much oh um and I want
to say I love you back but I want you to
take it the wrong way yeah so um you
have your podcast right right which will
what's it called its called a soccer
comic grant but all of the soccer come
small things calm be calm we're still
with that what's up with them too um all
things comedy defense Minecra soccer
soccer angry stomp around you if you
would just audit i know i love it it all
right and i went to your sherry killer
house their killer a circular house i do
how everything is like in play
you sent everything I you needed me in
orderly and I got a table or couch it's
very alike and MTV notice I a
minimalistic Obama nice modern you're
wanting me like it's a very lovely fine
yes Lanka yeah before before I moved in
this place was just a big pile of shoes
mart that it was all I was bit like like
dead women she yeah yeah the women to
until Devils people yeah yeah and just
pictures like old photographs actual
like photographs is like his like
spreading hooker's ass oh my don't you
post pictures of you the other hooker I
do like 34 I mean I don't follow yeah
video TV I'm audio the whole audio
department you're crazy anyway on god
bless america me give any shows lady
what a pleasant shows I was yeah i'll be
at the comedy store this week yeah yeah
and your Instagram and Twitter you know
it was common for both yeah yeah I'm
gonna be at the laugh out loud san
antonio this weekend next weekend he's
going to be a dad and improv and then i
get a week off because i need it because
it's too long yeah nere 10 through 12 of
san jose and probs oh that's a guy i
know i love who i love them on yeah and
then 15 through 17 schaumburg and frogs
room and then after that you're in
ontario improv sketch yeah no that's it
on top of it thanks guys I like the
relationship you man what you said I
like this is a bad thing on hey gets to
look smaller Graham and Tiger belly on
twitter at that Tiger Bella emails any
questions like you spoke at the tiger
belly at gmail com and you can follow it
on video
calamity k &
[Music]